Narrator: The Pokémon
in "Detective Pikachu"
have a new look, and they've
never seemed more real
or terrifying. That's in
large part thanks to this guy.
RJ Palmer: I'm RJ Palmer, I'm
a concept artist at Ubisoft,
I draw creatures and monsters,
and I worked on "Detective Pikachu."
Narrator: He started drawing
when he was just three years old.
He continued to hone his craft
at the San Francisco Academy of Art.
Then in 2012, his drawings
for an amateur fan art project
gained so much attention on the internet,
it ultimately landed him a
job on the new Pokémon film.
RJ: So I started drawing a shark dinosaur,
and that turned into the Pokémon Garchomp,
and people really, really responded to it,
so I kept drawing more.
Narrator: RJ used real
animals as inspiration.
RJ: The natural world is so inspiring,
and I think pulling from that,
as much as possible, is really cool.
Narrator: For example, Mewtwo
was a combination of several creatures.
RJ: Kangaroo, and a little bit of rhino,
and hairless cat, and some barn owl.
Narrator: For Charizard, he
focused on different lizards.
RJ: So I looked at a
lot of monitor lizards
and brought qualities of crocodilians
in there that I liked, as well.
Narrator: Surprisingly enough,
RJ's main tools for designing
his realistic Pokémon
were simply a Wacom tablet and Photoshop.
RJ: And I've got a second monitor up,
so I can have all my references.
Narrator: Ultimately, it
was the amount of time
and effort RJ poured into the project
that made his Pokémon come to life.
RJ researched every animal
he used for inspiration,
and in the end, each Pokémon he created
took 30 or more hours to complete.
RJ: The one that took the longest to make
is Tyrantrum.
Tyrantrum is my favorite Pokémon.
Narrator: He posted them on
the popular fan art
community site, DeviantArt,
and his work won over
fans on the internet.
It also got the attention
of the production designer
of "Detective Pikachu."
RJ: He gives me a call, and he's like,
"Would you like to work
on the Pokémon movie?"
And I'm in shock, it was amazing.
I've always been really into
Pokémon as just a franchise,
because I think it's
really fun and creative.
Narrator: He moved to LA
and worked on the film for seven months,
doing concept art for
characters and the environments.
He helped come up with the
initial designs for the Pokémon.
RJ: And then it gets given to
all sorts of crazy effects houses.
Narrator: While his Pokémon on DeviantArt
are more realistic, the ones
he designed for the film
had to be a bit more traditional.
RJ: So working on the movie,
they had to get more in line
with the cartoon aesthetic, I think.
You do a design, and the
people have opinions,
and then you do another design,
and they also still have opinions,
and so it's a constant back and forth,
trying to make one person happy,
which is going to make
somebody else unhappy,
and you have to try and
find a middle ground
that's going to work for people.
Narrator: Pikachu, as the star
of the film and franchise,
took a while to nail down and get right.
Pikachu: Pika pika!
Woman: Yeah, pika pika
pika, he's adorable!
RJ: Pikachu's one of the most
well known cartoon characters ever, right?
Narrator: Despite speaking english
and being a bit more
furry than the cartoon,
the Pikachu in the film
is different from his realistic design.
RJ: I based him on rodents and lagomorphs.
Lagomorphs are like rabbits,
just like small, woodland critters.
Narrator: But it was Mr. Mime
that really grabbed the
internet's attention.
Since his debut in the
trailer, he's become a meme.
RJ: Mr. Mime was always
going to be weird, right?
'Cause what do you make that thing?
When I did my realistic version of it,
I made it a frog, because it
can be so many weird things.
I think a detail that I didn't know
they were going to go for,
but the little shoulder pauldrons
actually look like kickballs.
I thought that was a pretty fun idea.
And the Jigglypuff I like.
In the Pokédex entry,
they talk about it having a
balloon-like skin texture,
which would probably be
pretty creepy in real life.
Narrator: So they made it more furry
with a curly wisp of
hair. In the end though,
it's the fans who have the final say.
RJ: Everybody has their own
idea of what Pokémon is,
and I've certainly encountered
that working on my own stuff.
I've had some very divisive
takes on certain Pokémon.
So I knew that was going to be a problem
going into the movie,
and so far, at least,
the response to the trailer,
at least from the circles that I've seen,
seem pretty positive.
Pikachu: Hi, yes, okay, a can?
Shoving? Pushing?
My problem is that I push people away
and then hate them for leaving?
Tim: He's saying you can shove it.
Pikachu: What, I can shove it?
Okay, that's it, no,
we're switching rolls.
I'm bad cop, you're good cop.
Tim: No no no no no, we're not cops.